foreign
let's go out to Charleston South
Carolina and talk to Isaac yo yo what's
up Isaac
hey man I'm as excited as opening day of
deer season I get to talk to the doctor
John deloney I on opening day of deer
season I don't talk to anybody just the
woods
hey man I'm doing good I appreciate you
taking taking the time to talk with me
and everything that y'all do up there at
Ramsey Solutions uh y'all y'all really
do help people with hope and change
lives so I'm really great and I'm a big
fan thank you my brother thank you thank
you what's up
well uh my question was about resentment
um you know
you know once once you're there uh can
you come back
um and if so how I know the I come
back is up to me but you know coming
back from it and maybe House shows so I
can certainly provide a little more
context yeah I I think coming out of the
gate knowing I'm always gonna answer
that question yes and whoo it's hard
right if you are in disgust and contempt
and resentment
I mean you're talking a control alt
delete on just about everything
um to come back together is it possible
100 absolutely so tell me what happened
how do we get here all right
well
um been married to my wife but this is
going on seven years
um we've been separated since March
early March
um but uh you know circling back to that
we got we got three kids under five
um so you know we've our marriage has
been raising kids for the most part
um short timeline we had a big job
change and a move back in July
um come August took a trip home and had
a little uh there's a falling out with
my parents and I didn't quite stand up
for her maybe as best as I could have
but um you know things started kind of
getting a little stressful from there
um and then come October she came to me
saying she wanted uh basically to start
separation process and things
came came clean about some infidelity
from years back
um that I didn't know about
um including with one of my really close
friends and groomsmen
um so that was that was a big shock and
um I was willing you know I wanted to
work with with her from there
forgiveness all that you know I was good
there and wanted to do everything I
could to keep what we had together
um and then you know it was kind of
going through that back and forth
process feeling like I was trying
everything I could then come January I
found out she was actually currently
uh being unfaithful with one of my very
close friends and co-workers
um so
yeah that was just another another
dagger in the back that um you know got
Twisted basically but so from that point
you know felt like I felt like I had a
direction I was going
um you know like I said parted ways in
March she's living elsewhere you know a
few miles down the road you know we
still have close relationship obviously
with our three kids and everything
um but uh just a few weeks ago she comes
back and
uh it ready to rated
realize she did wrong and wants to fix
things and
um honestly this is this is only one of
the few times in my life where I uh I
really just don't know what to do um
really just at a loss
um as far as how I feel and what to feel
so if you and I were sitting out
um on opening day in the woods
and they were sitting in a two-person
tree stand which means we are about two
inches from each other
and it was quiet
and I looked over at you and said what
are you gonna do
without trying to filter it without
trying to think through yeah but what
would you say
um
you know
what would you say go with your gut just
say it like I want to
um you know uh we uh
I want to
um that's you know that's what I want to
work towards but I just I just don't
know how um I want to try something on
and you and you you rejected
wholeheartedly if I'm wrong okay
all right I think you are done
and I think you want to want to because
you think that's the right thing
and you have a picture in your head
about people who quote unquote quit and
when she circled back for a third time
after destroying your life
destroying the life of her kids
and destroying
um your friendships
that little voice that said well
now that she wants to be back in if you
walk away You're the quitter
and I think something in your spirit
says I'm done
and you don't know what to do next
because this is a scary terrifying
proposition because this is somebody you
built a life with you created a family
with and you don't have a plan B
and yet here we are
tell me if I'm wrong
uh I mean I wouldn't say I wouldn't say
completely wrong
um
it's
yeah like I don't want to be done but it
it just it just seems impossible to not
be done almost
ah
Have you listened to this show before
yeah yes I have so you know I'm always
telling people to to find a path back
together and this one just for whatever
reason man maybe it's because I normally
shoot shows in the morning and it's the
afternoon but there is something in my
spirit that just is is grossed out by
this whole thing
all right
um I usually
um
I I usually believe there are two sides
to every one of these stories
am I wrong here this one feels very very
one-sided
uh as far as the actions that were done
it was pretty one-sided I mean you know
obviously nobody's a perfect husband and
things like that I disagree I'm
incredible I'm just kidding of course of
course no one's perfect but but I mean
but let's be honest in your whole life
you've never been married and a parent
of a kid
you were I've never been married in the
parent of two kids never been married
and a parent of three kids so y'all are
constantly having to rebuild and rebuild
and rebuild and so nobody does that
right of course you make design
decisions that are goofy and you put the
you know you put a foundation footer in
the wrong place that's just part of
being married and figuring things out
together
that's not a reason to go hook up with
somebody's best friend
and then lie about it
and make you feel crazy
that's not it's not Liberty to do it
again and it's funny when you were
telling me that my first thought was oh
she's practicing on him
she's practicing telling an old store to
see if it's okay to tell what's really
going on right now
right
and lo and behold
so here's what I'm gonna tell you if you
want to stay married to her you can stay
married to her this isn't resentment I
don't think I don't think you're there
yet this is Active Pain
resentment is when the smoke is cleared
and you realize oh we're not even in the
same house anymore
psychologically emotionally spiritually
we are too diff we have two different
lives you're not there yet man you're
still bleeding
right
she destroyed your family and I'm sorry
appreciate you appreciate you saying
that and you know
yeah I mean it's tough
um it really is and
um what do you do for a living
uh I'm a wildlife biologist okay all
right very cool
um
I'll say this as delicately as I can't
you can't fix this
right this is and I can't I can't fix
her and I know that like that but your
marriage can't be quote unquote fixed
it will have to be rebuilt from the
floor up
yeah and you for the first time and you
haven't done this in 10 years you're
gonna have to be very clear about what I
need
and
and she's gonna have to be very
empathetic towards those needs and be so
focused with like a laser beam on
empathy with you
I don't think she's got to enter
unless she has just seen the light
right
and rightly or wrong I I you know I'm I
might mom might be out to lunch with
this but for whatever reason I grade
these kind of things on a on a scale
and what I mean by that is somebody sits
down and says hey dude I was on a
business trip we were all at a dinner
and there was a couple of salesmen a
couple I don't know what happened but I
hooked up with somebody
um that's stupid and it's painful it's
hurtful
that's not hooking up with my husband's
best friend
and this was once once found out it was
continued on and kind of right and then
and then and then again
that's almost pathological
it's disgusting
and so when I'm thinking through like
man you bring forgiveness back I don't
know what happened I screwed up I got I
there was a month when I was just head
over heels with somebody at work and
what those things happen that's life
this is this is something different and
so I want you to hear me say you aren't
crazy
and you're not over feeling this thing
and you're not a bad guy for thinking
for starting to make plans of what comes
next in the world that you are now cast
into by yourself you're not crazy you're
not a bad guy
okay
all right you're a guy that was
legitimately done wrong
and I think the question is
what does co-parenting look like what
his friends look like
um can I ask you a real sensitive
question
absolutely when's the last time y'all
were together intimately when's the last
time you all slept together
uh probably
either back September
um except yeah before I knew about the
first stuff so because we were you know
kind of separate rooms type stuff like I
said from kind of September into August
the job and had like a hook up one night
or a hey I miss you kind of thing
dropping the kids off or something
no
yeah man I'm sorry
when you if you decide I'm out I'm done
my kids deserve better I deserve better
she's got a lot of healing to do and I'm
not the person that I can't can't drag
her through it
it's gonna hit you like a tsunami the
pain the reality of all of this
and
I don't want you to run from that okay
all right
you're gonna have to get a couple of
guys in your life you're not gonna have
to head into the storm you can't run
from this one man this just sucks
yeah I am I am blessed in my life you
know I've got I mean that's
considering everything that's happened
of I feel like I'm in a good place I've
got good people around me um you know
being in the new place still working on
working on new people around here but
I've I've got good people in my life and
that's good
um
they haven't stuck the dagger in my back
yet hey the first one the first one you
told him I said hey man you know
pressure's on you now you know
he said man I ain't gonna I don't even
know if I can call you on the phone no
more hey that's that's actually
I can imagine how awkward you could make
a like hanging out with a couple new
guys and y'all get to be good friends
and be like all right listen
if any one of you guys sleeps with my
wife I'm gonna kill you right I can
imagine dinner getting kind of strange
um
here here's here's the deal I want you
to hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of on your past change your future
uh just something for you to read
through and it's it's just the path out
man of sitting in this grief and what do
I do and where do I head
um where do I go now
I'm not gonna hate you I'm Not Gonna
Roll my eyes at you I'm gonna hug you if
you say nope we talked we had an honest
come to Isaac conversation we're going
to stay together great
and if you want to do that both of you
call me back I'll walk you through the
path back that y'all can start
if you decide
man this thing's been done since
September um it's been on life support
but it's been gone since September I'm
done
spark is gone this guy's just gone
Fire's out and um
if you want to do that call me back man
and we can figure out where to go from
there I want you to never feel like you
don't have anybody to call or a place to
go
um or a place to turn
I'm just heartbroken for you man I'm
sorry that your wife did this to you
then she blew everything up
take care of take care of Isaac and take
care of those little ones